foreign
let's go to Michael in Buffalo what's up
Michael
what's up
what's up dude oh goodness uh a lot a
lot what's up man
so I uh the reason I wanted to talk to
you is my question is is I've uh haven't
been a good husband or father and my
wife now who I've been with for five
years is at which end and I just I want
to be that man that she she deserves and
I just I fail miserably and
in every step that I tried to do
anything
well first thanks for being brave
um usually these kind of calls end up
with me coming at you a little bit is
that cool yes sir all right I'm straight
up with that cool um well thanks for
thanks for being open man I know that's
not an easy thing to say to look in the
mirror and put both hands on the counter
and look in the mirror and say I'm I'm
I'm not the man and the husband and the
and the dad I want to be so thanks for
starting there
um what does that mean that you're not
good
yeah just because I wasn't faithful uh
tour and uh and multiple times so it was
basically a Serial tutor and liar and
then I went on just to basically live it
how I wanted to and then I met my wife
now and
and some of those same traits or aspects
are coming back out you know she uh at
times I'm not truthful or you know I lie
and it's not just that I lie but then
when I lie I guess I might go sleep and
try to make her believe my lie and and
uh you know I've been unloyal to her in
ways of you know talking about
things with that relationship involving
her but putting the blame more on her
than myself and uh you know even to the
point where they were a lot of things
she says you know it just appears that
I'm selfish and narcissistic and and I
lack you know empathy and having been
faithful to her you know you know
infidelity not it's not that I've
cheated on her I haven't cheated on her
I think you have I think you have yeah I
mean she I mean she said you know I've
not physically cheated on her but at the
beginning like I did talk to other women
but then that stopped but then like I've
you know financially uh I had you know
shown infidelity emotionally
um so and she's she's
a great woman she straight up tells me
how it is and she reminds me of the
female version of you hey hold on let's
start oh this only works if you you're
honest with me yes sir have you cheated
on your wife
absolutely not and I've told her that
you know of course she doesn't believe
me because I've that's my door yeah I
can never that's one area that and I've
told her like like my lesson in that she
makes me happy she fulfills me and I I
know you know she's not she's not the
issue and your first wife wasn't the
issue
for some reason you believe that you're
not good enough why
[Music]
I said uh what I've brought up but for
years in my first marriage I uh I never
and ever brought it up until
going to counseling with my first wife
and uh even my parents never knew I was
I was in the last city as a child okay I
I held that end by the neighbor boy
babysat me okay and I helped out in for
all those years and uh you know as far
as like the the the aces score like I've
done that like I I don't score high on
that so it's you know my parents are
together I you know have a good family
um I'm the only one in the family
divorced my siblings are married and
happy and I know but listen listen when
you when you have something like that
then your body learns that there is no
safety in trusting relationships
and so when you have a trusting
relationship everything in your body
says run says discomfort it sounds every
alarm you got
it does and one of the ways to shut the
alarms off is alcohol and one of the
ways to shut the alarms off is To Go
Achieve just start running right work 90
hours a week and one of the ways to shut
the alarms off is to go sleep with
someone else or if you're not
technically sleeping with somebody else
another way to shut the alarms off is to
start texting somebody and texting
somebody and texting somebody because
you get that little bitty
it feels good right it feels like you're
alive for a second right yes yes sir it
did
so think of it this way and again I'm
being super simplistic here but let's
just say one story equals one action
okay
your body knows that intimate
relationships are gonna get you hurt and
so when you enter into one it covers you
up with those big heavy weighted
blankets
right and you can't breathe and you get
scared and you don't like who you become
right and then you go chase excitement
and ultimately my guess is you've beat
yourself up pretty bad over the last few
years and to be honest with you
rightfully so because you're treating
these women who loved you like garbage
right
um
you're running through this cycle that
you believe that you're not good enough
and the truth isn't good enough and so
you confirm it by your actions right
that you're not a good dad you're not a
good husband and then you just do the
things that backfill that story and make
it right
and so hey you you I think Jenna told me
you read you read the book you read my
book did that rattle your cage at all
did you roll your eyes at it no I didn't
I didn't read it actually listened to it
online uh through one of the library
Services
um it was good it was really good and I
shared it with my wife and my wife was
usually since we both listened to uh
so
um she I actually told her about certain
parts and you know how I need to go I
actually want to get the books so I can
actually keep notes on it and and try to
take those steps in there that you've
you uh emphasize what have you tried
what have you tried
uh I
as far as the book goes I I don't know
throw the book out use it for two play
on a camping trip I don't care about the
book like what have you tried
to stop relying to your family to stop
cheating on your family
and and that's and I you know with my
wife
and I am truthful about things getting
the reactions I know you know either I
get the reaction or I'm projecting what
the reaction is going to be and then and
then it basically triggers me into like
well I don't want that reaction so I'm
gonna say this so I get a different
reaction and and then that my ultimately
triggers a worse reaction right
so so here's your way forward ma'am
here's your way forward
I wish it was more complex than what I'm
about to say
at some point like an alcoholic has to
look in the mirror and say I I I want to
but I can never drink again
um
or like me
I want to
but I have a problem with food I do
and so I have to create an environment
where I can only make good choices
just it
you have to decide
Point Blank I will never lie again
you have to decide Point Blank I will
never cheat again and then you have to
create a world that makes that very very
difficult and you have to practice it
that's it I wish it was more complex
than that it's just simply not
and I tell you this as someone who lied
a lot
I exaggerated about everything and I
watched a professional ex just implode
their life
and it was this weird moment that was
I will never be dishonest again for as
long as I live
and it has been really uncomfortable
and when I say practice here's what that
means you will lie again it becomes
second nature right and you're probably
pretty good at it and it just comes out
you stop either right then or you Circle
back and you say
I didn't tell you the truth and you have
to tell your wife I need some Grace when
I Circle back here was the rule I gave
my students like when I called them in
and said hey they found a bunch of drugs
in your residence hall room
I would always tell them before I talk
to you and I need you to know you got 24
hours and I'm gonna I'm going to take it
as though you told me the truth now
because I know what happens when someone
just blasts you with an accusation it's
so easy it's second nature just to go no
no no no
if you come back within 24 hours and
change your story I'm gonna I'm gonna
take it as though you told me that the
first time after 24 hours I'm gonna try
to remove you from this campus because
you're a dishonest person and I don't
want our degree hanging on your wall
right right so yeah come up with some
sort of contract with your wife and say
I'm going to practice with all that I am
to be a person of integrity
and that means there's going to be
moments that I fire off with something
that's not true and I need to catch
myself in that moment or I need that
moment to haunt me so bad
that I loot back and change it and I
need you to hear me and exhale and say
okay he's working hard
all right practice not being a cheater
means you delete every single woman in
your phone that's not your wife now and
you delete social media now
yes I don't even have social media so if
you have a problem with pornography and
checking out
um uh
all the various sites for getting into
people's living rooms and in their bed
then get rid of your computer
you're an addict
and your addiction is deception
and then underneath all that man at some
point you've got to decide that you're
not a piece of crap
yeah that's
invested biggest challenge it is it is
you got to love yourself you gotta you
gotta you know
you gotta be truthful to yourself and
but no you're not truthful to yourself
yeah you lie to yourself you tell
yourself that you suck and you tell
yourself that you're an idiot and you
tell yourself that you're worth the
abuse and you should have done something
different and now you're the divorced
one in the house
and you're you've got all these stories
that you continue to tell yourself over
and over and over and over again
yes and you got to choose to change that
story
I also believe like I told you the
reason I told you actions first is I
think we can't just sit especially as uh
one is deeply and traumatic and
entrenched is what you experienced with
sexual abuse from an older kid in your
neighborhood
I don't think you can think your way out
of that I think you act your way out of
that and you act your way up by
practicing
practice the new behaviors
right okay
and a hundred percent chance you will
stumble and fail and fall right on your
face
and that's when you become the husband
and
dad that your wife and kids need because
you pick yourself back up
and you say I'm sorry and then you go
again
they should be they mean nothing right
right and so it's be about reclaiming
that word in your home you remember if
you listen remember listen in the book
The and I got this from uh James Clear
create an identity and backfill your
life so that that identity becomes
natural meaning don't try to I want to
bench press 235 pounds that's a goal and
you'll stumble on that goal right or
you'll get the goal and then so what you
can bench press 235 pounds nobody cares
you're a grown man
be a person who takes care of their body
be a person who's a steward of their
body so you're going to be a person
who's a great father and backfilling
that identity I always tell the truth
always
I don't cheat on my kid's mother
when I'm having bad days or when my body
takes off on me I had a really hard day
yesterday Michael you know what I did I
left I canceled all my meetings and left
because I knew that I would be I would
not be able to be present in
conversations and I knew conversations
with me I would be very sharp tongue I
just know that it's rare that it happens
but I knew it and so I took myself out
of the situation
okay that we're looking for this type of
self-awareness here and you don't have
it yet
right okay
yes so I'll I would ask you are your
kids worth it you know the answer is yes
is your wife worth it you know the
answer is yes
the ultimate question is are you
yes
do you believe that are you lying to me
too
okay will you do the work then
I will definitely do the work and that's
you know I've been telling her I'm
working on it but she's like I don't see
it yeah she doesn't she doesn't because
I don't think you're working on it I
think you're wanting to work on it I
think you're TR it's kind of like
every couple of days you skip the donuts
in the work room and you tell people
you're trying to eat better
that's not a plan
right very good point right
exactly dead on yeah
you've got to set out an identity here's
who I'm gonna be then you've got to
backfill those actions and quite
honestly at this point I'd bring her
along with you
and say what does realize anymore over
time
but see that's just that's what that
goes back to that same you just dumped
it back in the bucket you're a waste of
somebody's time you're not
yeah you're treating your wife like crap
but you yourself are not a waste of time
right you're not a lost cause and the
more you think about oh well I'll just
that's actually a move dude that's a
deceptive move
right yeah and I'm not saying I'm a
waste of time I'm saying I don't want to
waste her time then don't then don't
then don't you get to choose that
right
exactly right don't waste your time sit
down and say what does this rebuilding
trust look like and if you would like
um I'll clip this call and we'll send it
to you it doesn't come out for a while
but we'll clip it to you and send it to
you and you and your wife can listen to
it tonight or tomorrow
so here's what I need you to do y'all
both need to sit at a table
and she's got to put some hard
boundaries on you because this is just
gonna go and it's gonna go and it's
gonna go in your second marriage can end
up just like your first one
don't do that to her don't do that to
you don't do that to those kids
I will never lie again
and when I do I will admit it I will own
it and I will practice circling back out
of it and I'm going to let her speak
into how do I get out I will never be
disloyal and dishonorable to my wife
again
period
I will see her on every text on every
email I send to another woman I will
come home she will see the bank accounts
we will share bank accounts if you don't
already that happens today I'm going to
do these things that will show this is
who I am
and this is who I am becoming this is
who I'm on the road to be and give her
some voice into what trust looks like
and then she's gonna have a role to play
too because she's going to be graceful
because you're trying something that you
have not been successful with for a long
long time
and if ultimately you got to go get some
counseling to deal with that childhood
trauma which is a big one I don't care
what your Ace score is that's a huge
thing
to get some healing with that do it
but I'm going to tell you I'm set I'm
bifurcating I'm separating that from
your actions you can stop cheating and
you can stop lying and you can't stop uh
being dishonest with your money and with
your white all that stuff and you have
to deal with your childhood stuff it's
all it's it's it can be braided together
I'm pulling it apart
choose to be different my brother
call me back after that meeting let me
know how that meeting goes